Here's a different type of compound inequality. This one uses the word, or. I
want any number of x that makes this inequality true, or any number of x that
makes this inequality true. It doesn't have to be true for both of them. I'm
going to do some leg work and go ahead and solve these inequalities. Now would
be a good point to pause the video and see if you get the same solutions I do.
For the first inequality, we get x is less than or equal to 1. For the second
inequality, we divide by negative 3, so we reverse the inequality sign and we
get x is greater than or equal to 3. Any number less than or equal to 1 or any
number greater than or equal to 3 will satisfy one of these inequalities. Let's
see this on a number line. So, here's our number line. Any value to the left of
1 will work for this inequality and any value to the right of 3 will satisfy
this inequality. Just like all the other equations and inequalities we've done,
we can check our answer to make sure we're right. I'm going to check 0 for this
inequality and I'm going to check 4 four for this inequality. Remember, 0 won't
work for this one, but it will work for this one. We just need to make sure it
will work for one or the other. If I plug in zero for x for the first
inequality, I get negative 4 is less than or equal to 0. This is true. If I plug
in x equals 4 into the second inequality, I get negative 12 is less than or
equal to 9. This is also true. This is great. These solutions work for the first
inequality, and these solutions work for the second. They don't need to work for
both, they just need to work for one or the other.